all right welcome to Hannity a lot of
news breaking this Friday night while
two deranged angry lunatics fight it out
in what is an increasingly nasty battle
for the Democratic nomination there was
president Trump fully focused on the job
serious issues earlier today he toured
what is the devastation sadly to our
friends in Tennessee multiple tornadoes
ravaging the state on Tuesday night
killing at least 25 people including
five children on the ground the
president offered his full support vowed
to provide whatever federal assistance
the state will need and then he flew to
Atlanta we met with officials at the
Centers for Disease Control and
Convention the CDC for short the
president's trip to the CDC marks what
has been the single most aggressive and
most thorough response the quickest
response by any modern-day
administration to any type of pandemic
or virus outbreak in this case the
corona virus but predictably sadly you
can't even agree to work together to
prevent people from getting a virus I
don't think the virus cares if it's a
liberal or conservative infected
anyway the mob and the media Democrats
what do they do they want to use a
deadly virus as a political weapon
against the president seemingly rooting
for this to be quote Trump's Katrina
they want you to believe that the spread
of Corona is the president's fault and
he's not doing enough to protect you
they couldn't be further from the truth
because we have the facts in spite of
the New York Times saying it's the Trump
virus no it's not the Trump virus if
you're feeling bad you know how to blame
Trump no it's not either here's the
timeline first identified December 30th
oh they had a virus in the Wuhan
province area of China by the way and
then it is identified as was having
pneumonia symptoms then it was January
7th we first actually named it the
corona virus remember that now Corona
this one is a corona variation of a
previous Corona on January 31st the
Trump administration they in record time
declared a public health emergency
Americans returning for most areas
impacted to quarantine manda
taury a military base is something that
hadn't been done for decades in this
country February 2nd the temporary
travel ban went into effect for all non
US citizens who recently visited the
entire country of China unprecedented
steps by the president he made the call
and we now know and through my interview
and others that most officials thought
it was too early for a travel ban or for
any quarantine in the following days the
president formed a task force filled it
with the top the greatest the best
scientific medical professionals in the
world led by the vice president of the
United States on February 29th the
temporary travel ban was extended to
quote any foreign national who has
visited Iran within the last fourteen
days on the same day the State
Department issued new travel
restrictions to Italy with the outbreak
has been fairly large and in South Korea
also on the 29th the FDA cut regulations
allowing a more rapid testing response
and capacity for coronavirus on March
2nd the president met with
pharmaceutical executives where he
learned that phase 1 testing of this
vaccine is imminent record time again
March 3rd the administration ordered the
CDC to lift all restrictions on testing
today the President signed an eight
billion dollar emergency spending
package into law even donated his salary
to the Department of Health and Human
Services to fight back against the virus
the media mobs weaponization and
politicizing of this very serious issues
beyond predictable and disgraceful yeah
last week believe it or not New York
Times said if you're feeling sick and
you know who to blame these are the
Trump virus because if the dog bites the
bee stings and you're feeling sad its
Donald Trump's fault
instead of what well maybe coming
together providing you with truth and
facts what have they been doing sowing
fear panic distrust now make no mistake
like with every pandemic even the one
that Biden and Obama did not react as
quickly to as they should have in 2009
and 10 that was h1n1 and better known as
the swine flu the corona virus is
serious you should be informed about
real risks and
real dangers as with the flu as with any
virus as with any pandemic this is not
the first major pandemic possible
pandemic to impact the United States but
we've been impacted far less thankfully
than other countries but we want to cure
for everybody
2009 here's their timeline under
President Obama h1n1 that virus infected
61 million Americans leading to what
13,000 deaths that within almost a year
so put that in perspective and by the
way took six months for Obama to declare
the full national emergency so far
they're around 250 cases of corona virus
in the u.s. 250 too many according to
the Assistant Secretary of Health the
overall estimated mortality rate for
corona is less than 1% okay pretty low
now the h1n1 that tend to impact the
young children this one tends to impact
older people a little bit more
especially those that are more
susceptible that have weakened immune
systems the elderly with other
underlying health issues watch yourself
the best estimates now of the overall
mortality rate for Kovan 19 is somewhere
between 0.1 percent and 1 percent okay
that's lower than you heard probably in
many reports lower than what fake News
CNN MS DNC would like you to believe
perhaps the world is not coming to an
end it's not the president's fault when
the president put the travel ban in
effect fake news CNN says well we're
going to stigmatize other country Joe
Biden said the president's a xenophobe
well we have other news they've been
predicting the downfall of our economy
not happening either our economy Oh in
spite of wall street always being
jittery it continues to show the
fundamental strength is that an all-time
high why because in February we now know
as of today we added a whopping 273
thousand new jobs causing the
unemployment rate to fall yet again yes
a 50-year low of 3.5%